here we go
hey everyone I'm Joe I'm gonna let you
in on one of my guilty pleasures that is
Taco Bell because I'm a chef I like to
make things at home today I'm gonna
recreate a Doritos locos taco and see if
homemade is better than fast food first
things first we're gonna make our
tortilla Doritos locos taco shell I have
all of my me--some Clawson ingredients
here starting with my Doritos og nacho
cheese flavor not the Cool Ranch I'm
gonna put the chips into the food
processor flour masa some of this nacho
cheese powder dust magical stuff that
bumps up the nacho cheesy goodness a
little bit of salt last but not least
baking powder that's gonna act as a
little leavening agent here we go and
all right I have this here finely ground
and then I have two more ingredients we
have water and lard Larina rendered pork
fat if you want to keep this vegetarian
no problem to sub out a little bit of
vegetable shortening I'm gonna get the
lid back on now I am pouring in my lard
slowly and then followed by my water all
right
dough ball everything's come together
nicely you can see it's cleaned off the
sides of the bowl here we got this
beautiful orange Dorito color I'm
curious how this cooks up if the color
gets lighter or darker we're definitely
going in the right direction all right
you know pop this into the fridge I'll
see you and you in 30 minutes all right
let's get into this I have my tortilla
station here a couple pieces of
parchment paper a heavy pan if you do
not have a tortilla press I have another
pan heating up here kind of like a
griddle and a landing zone
for all of my taco shells I'm going to
start with a small ball of dough we're
going for about the size of a golf ball
maybe a little bigger not a baseball how
to bowling ball that might be a burrito
keep this wrapped so it doesn't dry out
in between the parchment paper pan on
top get a bit of weight the moment of
truth we have a tortilla we're gonna
peel it off very gently lay it onto the
griddle you could hear it sizzle I'm
gonna let that start sizzling and make
another tortilla you know for me taco
bell's one of those things that's like
nostalgic Ollie talked about just about
any time not ashamed to admit back you
can see the tortilla here is cooking up
it's starting to dry out a little bit
we're gonna get up underneath there and
flip it here we are
spatula flown in there you can see the
tortilla is starting to hold up much
easier than flipping eggs or a pancake
we're not gonna cook the tortilla all
the way on the griddle here I want to
try baking these I think baking versus
frying is going to give us this really
nice crunch on the outside I'm not sure
what Taco Bell does it but I'm going
with the bank method here I want to find
out if it's better than fast food I'm
finishing up my last taco tortilla here
I'm gonna transfer it I got a been
preheated to 400 degrees Fahrenheit
three minutes super fast just to crisp
them up all right here we are
tortillas hot right out of the oven
while they're still hot carefully with
your hands pick them up and we're going
to drape them into our taco molds here
and while still warm Doritos Locos Tacos
to Taco Bell have this seasoning mix on
the outside I don't know if it's more
ground Doritos I have nacho cheese
powder I think that's going to help
emulate and replicate the og original
I'm gonna set these aside let them cool
let them take their shape and work on my
taco filling
there's one thing I've made more than
pasta it's probably taco filling I'm
gonna show you a couple little easy
tricks along the way starting with
dicing your onions and garlic
everybody always cries has a hard time
with this asking for tips and tricks'
food processor helps along the way half
an onion couple cloves of garlic a
little bit of oil in here throw on the
lid and we're pulsing on and off on and
off we want a pulse so we don't make a
vegetable puree here I'm gonna pop this
open and just scrape down the sides to
make sure we don't have any rogue chunks
one more time we are fully chopped not a
paste because I already have oil in here
from the chopping I don't need any oil
in my pan we're gonna start this over
medium-low heat I want to give the
onions and garlic a little head start
ahead of the ground beef make sure that
we don't have any of that raw onion or
garlic flavor and then we're gonna boost
it up with some more dried onions and
dried garlic I don't think they use
fresh onions or garlic in the Taco Bell
version but we're going to double down
on our onions and our garlic because
more better and more delicious looking
good here soft cooked down time to add
our ground beef I'm gonna clear a little
landing zone down here in the bottom I
like to use the 80/20 stuff 80% beef 20%
fat fat is flavor
in this case we're trying to out taco
the bell we're gonna slowly start to
break this down time to add all of our
spices some ground cumin ground
coriander cayenne pepper garlic powder
granulated onions paprika chili powder
and then a couple of the secret
additions here beef bouillon cube ground
boost of that beefy flavor and then a
little [ __ ] of MSG I know Taco Bell
does it I think we need it to compete
and at the end of the day Emma she has a
bad rap but there's really
nothing wrong with it and a little bit
of sugar and last but not least salt to
season I'm gonna get those spices worked
in here to the beef and then I'm gonna
actually switch tools we're gonna lose
the spatula onto a beef potato
multitasking masher and this is actually
going to get down in there and help us
make sure we have no big beef nuggets or
beef chunks if you don't break up your
beef at this point while it's still raw
you're gonna have a really hard time
breaking it down later this thing's
awesome all right let this cook down for
about five minutes it's smelling good
getting nice and brown around the edges
let our ground beef braised getting nice
and tender deglazing is just adding some
sort of liquid to a pan that has
caramelized and gotten a little bit of
crusty bits on the bottom the deglazing
is going to help incorporate all of that
back into the mix all right we're gonna
let this cook down for about ten more
minutes
we're really trying to duplicate that
stewed beefy goodness that you find
inside of taco bell we are on our way
there all right our water has cooked
down time for one of the last additions
here we're gonna use corn starch to
thicken the mix give it a beautiful
consistency I've reserved some of the
water here we're gonna mix the corn
starch with the cold water a little
whisk and right down into our beef
mixture we'll bring this right back up
to a simmer it's starting to thicken up
now I am going to employ my last tack is
an immersion blender with a low speed
we're just going to buzz up about a
quarter of this we're not gonna
you're a the whole thing there we go
now I think we're ready to assemble our
tacos it's Taco Time I have my Doritos
locos taco shells here all of my
toppings and my sour cream gun if you
guys are a Taco Bell connoisseur like
myself you know you cannot make Taco
Bell tacos without the caulking gun that
loads up the sour cream obviously we're
going with Supremes here because if
you're not eating supreme how I'll see
you livin starting with our taco meat on
the bottom obviously we're not too
worried about portion control
next comes the sour cream the moment
I've been waiting for oh my goodness
sour cream guns so incredibly satisfying
this is actually a frosting gun we
couldn't get the sour cream gun but did
the job next is our shredded lettuce
we're using iceberg here maximum crunch
factor shredded cheese and last but not
least our tomatoes I have my tacos
assembled I need some Taco Bell tacos to
compare these with and I want to taste
them side by side all right I have my
two versions of tacos taco bell Doritos
Locos og original tacos and then I have
our homemade tacos with the Doritos
ground up into the shells judging just
based on visuals alone here I think we
did a really good job both looking fully
loaded I'm just gonna get right in there
try the the taco bell ones first I'm
doing this for science obviously super
thin crispy shell ground beef always the
same never wavering the sour cream nice
cooling note in the center I mean I
could eat good dozen of those but now
I'm excited to see how our homemade
version compares to the mix
that's pretty awesome our filling I love
our filling more that homemade filling I
think it's a little meteor a little
juice here the flavors kind of shine a
little more you actually get all the
different spices the onions the garlic
the chilies if I had to eat another one
of these definitely gonna go with the
homemade one and not just because I made
them promise they're both really good
thanks for watching if there's any other
fast foods you want me to try and see if
homemade is better than the fast food
please leave a comment below and we'll
do this again if you guys just notice
the tacos on my shirt I mean I live for
taco day
you